everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm and today we're in game 11
of the 2018 World Chess Championships
there's 12 games total so one game after
this we have 10 draws up into this
points if you've been following along
you know that it's been draw after draw
after draw but it comes down to these
final two games Magnus Carlsen playing
the white pieces today there will be a
break tomorrow before game number 12
generally they've been playing 2 days
back-to-back and then a rest day these
final two games there is a rest stay in
between so Fabiano regardless of the
result today will have the white pieces
in the final 12th game but Magnus
Carlsen this is his last shot in the
classical variation time control as the
white pieces now may have some options
later on if they get to the tie breaker
the blitz rapid portion of the
tournament but Magnus Carlsen
he had a day off what does he come up
with and he starts with pawns who efore
paani 590 ft 3 Knight to f6 if you're
not super familiar with this opening
this is the Petrov defense this is
Fabiano's favorite defense by far he
studied this more than anything else
Magnus Carlsen has only played this one
so far in the tournament and it was a
head scratcher then because why would
you play against your opponent's
favorite defense but that's exactly what
Magnus Carlsen decided as his final
opening to play Knight takes on e5 this
is the main variation pawn d6 definitely
want to make sure you're always playing
pawn to d6 if you're not familiar you
can watch the other video where Magnus
Carlsen play this or you can just watch
my video on the Tetra of defense but
then Magnus Carlsen comes back tonight
to f3 now early in the tournament he did
play Knight to d3 was an odd move but he
ended up with a pretty good game even
with Fabiano being so well versed in the
Petrov defense this one he goes back to
more of the main line with Knights f3
Knight takes down here on e4 Knight up
to c3 these are all the common lines
that everyone
is familiar with what's interesting is
they played the first ten moves in under
two minutes two total minutes for all of
the first ten moves from both players
and they went for the variation to
castle on the queenside for magnus
carlsen so really it just becomes a race
of who can attack their opponents side
faster Fabiano did decide to deviate
from the main line here on move number
nine instead of immediately attacking on
the Queen side he plays Knight to f6
some of his preparation that probably
went into the tournaments if you have a
favorite movie probably spend more time
on that than anything else just trying
to figure out where you can find small
little advantages magnus carlsen didn't
to him take long to play Bishop to d3
and then pawn c5 so these are the 10
moves that took under two minutes both
sides extremely prepared for the
situation then we look at right here the
next move is the first move the master
Carlsen or any player took over 20
seconds he took about ten minutes on
this next move that's work over here to
e1 just centralizing his pieces in the
center of the board Bishop to e6
attacking this pawn right here two ways
to really defend this pawn to c4 is one
of them
this is defended by the bishop here on
d3 or could just play King over here to
b1 and yes you could play pawn to c4 you
don't have to worry about your King
coming over just yet to b1 it's still
protected here on a two if you were to
see something like pawn to b5 even if
you take here the bishop can't come down
to a 2 because pawn to b3 this is gonna
block in the bishop that Bishop is going
to fall but we do see Magnus Carlsen not
even wanting to worry about the pawn
over here decides to play King to b1 now
Queen to a5 and at this point decides
okay I need to block this off both the
bishop and the Queen here are attacking
the pawn I need to go ahead and play
pawn to c4 my opinion this is exactly
what Fabiano wanted to do and he takes
the Queen down here on d2 from a fan's
perspective not necessarily what we want
to see
thirteen moves in both sides have
already gotten their Queens off the
board but if you look at from Fabiana
perspective the Petrov defense is
already very draw he knows that this is
madness Carlson's last chance as white
if he can just defend correctly and get
a drawl he's gonna go in with the prep
day for game 12 for everything that he's
been working for his entire life he has
one game as white if he wins he will be
the world champion
the second american-born player ever
since Bobby Fischer so that is what is
at stake for him so trading down Queens
makes a lot of sense Ponce aged six from
Fabiano just blocking off the g5 square
here and Max Carson plays an interesting
move I really just like pawn to h3 the
knight coming down here to g4 seems like
something I don't want to have to deal
with if I'm Manish Carlsen he plays
Knight to h4 I and I really expected
here just the knight to come down to g4
attacking both of these pawns right here
that's not what madness Carlson was met
with instead we see rook to e8 from
Fabiano and then Knight to g6 the pond
can't take here unless he wants to give
up the bishop on e6 recognizing that yes
can attack this bishop here on e7 freely
because this pawn is now overloaded with
what it's trying to do Knight comes down
here to g4 now Bishop comes off the
board rook takes and then rook up here
to e 2 now this is a pseudo trap there's
a lot of these moves that you'll see at
high level play you do not want to take
with the rook here or excuse me in the
night here on h2 because f3 is going to
eventually trap the knight there's no
way for the knight to escape there's a
couple ways that white can attack this
Bishop up here to f4 if you were to see
something you know pawn down to g5 to
stop the Bishop coming up here you can
just play the rook over to h1 so no real
good option for black here so he
correctly after the route comes to e 2
to protect the one pawn he needs to on
f2 he brings his
back here to e5 magnus carlsen does have
the bishop Perry wants to attack that so
after the bishop to f4 he decides to go
ahead and take here on d3 rook
recaptures and then rook to d7 now
magnus carlsen has a couple options he
does have the pawn exposed here on c4 so
he could play something to defend that
instead he has both the rook and the
bishop here attacking the pawn here on
d6 decides to go ahead and take that
exchange down material also giving up
his pawn here on c4 he has a double pawn
on the C file so giving that up
probably not the worst thing for Magnus
Carlsen Bishop takes here on d6 rook to
d8 rook defends it and then the bishop
takes here on c4 so you can see already
23 moves in they've exchanged quite a
bit of material on the board
King to see one just centralizing this
it also opens up the door for the pawn
here on a two Fabiano does correctly
decide yeah I'm not gonna fall for that
trap and I'm play pawn to b6 same thing
as we looked at before Bishop to a2 is
going to be met by pawns who b3 that's
just not something
Fabiano wants to deal with so instead he
says yeah I'm gonna go and solidify that
pawn chain right here
Bishop comes back to b4 and this is a
very important square after the rook
takes and the King takes here then we
see pawn to a6 now you you'll see how
different this is if instead of pawn to
a6 the bishop takes here on a 2 it's a
little bit different than it was before
pawn to b3 now we have pawns of c4 and
things start to get a little interesting
here King to c1 pawn takes King up here
to be 2 but then after the pond takes
and the King takes the bishop then the
pawn can't come down to c1 the bishop is
defending that correctly so that's why
that bishop there on f4 is extremely
important so in the game after King to
d2 we see pawn to a6 in this position I
think everyone can look at and say that
from material standpoint both sides are
cool six ponds both have a bishop magnus
carlsen has a king that's a little more
in the center involved into the game but
both sides have opposite color bishops
generally what you're gonna see in this
type of in game is White's gonna look to
put all of his pawns on the dark squares
Fabiano has a light square bishop so you
can just pretty much make that piece
irrelevant and Fabiana is gonna try to
do the opposite put all of his pieces a
material on the light square so that
this dark square bishop cannot attack
any of them right now if you look at it
the King sides pretty much protected all
the ponds this King is defending
everything correctly
Fabiano just has to worry about these
two pawns right here magnus carlsen
first he has to deal with this pawn
right here under attack let's go ahead
and get that on a dark square the best
way for Fabiana to continue would be
something like Bishop to f1 this is
attacking this pawn after the pawn moves
to g3 getting a dark square he could
play pawn to b5 and then doesn't really
matter where white goes he could play
pawn c4 getting him all on light squares
doesn't have to worry about the bishop
instead he plays a really odd move to me
he plays King to f8 not only is this not
what you should be doing but it also
allows your opponent to just get a free
pawn because Bishop to c7 pawn has to
push forward and then Bishop to d6
checking the King why is the King here
on f8 the King moves and then Bishop
takes on c5 now still very difficult for
Magnus Carlsen to turn this into a win
but Fabiano playing so flawless getting
into the endgame just to give up a pawn
seems odd to me pawn to h5 King III just
centralizing King to d7 king before pawn
g6 she could see Fabiano already has all
of his pawns on the light squares
exactly what we talked about pawn to g3
not even gonna wait for father Yan to
bring his pawn down here or Bishop down
here to f1 just go ahead and push that
pawn up to g3 getting it on the dark
squares Bishop down here to e2 bishop f8
King to a c6 and then we start to go
through just a series of moves as both
sides trying to find a weakness in their
opponent's position they won
get there Kings heavily involved into
the action that's really the only option
they have to attack some of these
squares since their bishops can't attack
their opponents pawns they're on the
opposite colors but they went about 25
moves exchanged all the material off the
board just to come to the endgame that
you see here pawn to AB III Bishop down
here to d1
attacking the pawn king comes back to d3
to defend that Bishop g4 starts to push
on the Queen side immediately once the
bishop goes to the King side Madison
says I'll try to attack on the Queen
side pawn to c4 Bishop comes up to
attack King protects it pawn c4 so
Magnus Carlsen does have a passed pawn
it's gonna be very difficult to push
that but Bishop to g4 pawn up here to c5
on that dark square as we talked about
Bishop to e6 Bishop up here to h6 then
we just come through you can see both
sides trying to find a small small
advantage but very very difficult and
then Magnus Carlsen says yeah I have a
pawn advance maybe I can exchange some
it's you're off the board and find a
weakness in my opponent's Fabiano
playing extremely well just dancing back
and forth knowing that it's gonna be
very difficult for his opponent to do
anything making sure his King doesn't
move from this square here on c6 he
knows this Bishop can't move it and the
King can never get close enough so
there's no way that that King is going
to be forced to move that square then we
have pawn to f5 Bishop comes down here
to be won and then a very interesting
move we have Bishop down to f2
now this is on move 55 if you look at it
seems odd Magnus Carlsen allows his
opponent to come down to b1 and almost
freely take this pawn here on f5 it's
protected by the pawn on g6 there's a
lot of ways for him to protect them but
instead he plays Bishop to f2 doesn't
have to worry about defending the square
here on h4 but this is the last and
final attempt for Magnus Carlsen delay a
trap to get his opponent to make a
mistake now
Fabiana did not fall for the trap
the trap would be Bishop taking here on
f5 because pawn to h5 is a killer and if
you can kind of look at this and see the
pawn can't take because the bishops
going to fall Magnus Carlsen is gonna
win this very very easily if instead you
look at this and say okay the bishop is
under attack the pawns going to come up
here to h6 or just freely take here one
of those options more likely pawn up
here to h6 maybe the bishop comes back
to c2 pawn to h6 pawn to g5 needs to
open up the door for the light-square
bishop to defend the h7 square but then
the king can just start gobbling up a
material King to f6 to take this pawn
you can see if the King tries to come
over here to the a3 pawned he really
like to take this we can have his own
past pawn but this opens up the door it
can't move too far or the C pawn is
going to promote from Magnus Carlsen as
well if the bishop comes up here sure
King to g7 going to have to take the
pawn the bishops going to fall Magnus
Carlsen will have a very good game from
here as well so instead he does not fall
for the trap he plays Bishop to c2 and
at this point both sides decide to go
ahead and draw would have been terrible
if Fabiano after 11 games ended up
falling for that
Bishop to f5 but he had plenty of time
to look at and see that yeah I'm not
falling for that trap so after 55 moves
they decide to draw I'll be honest as a
spectator I expected more for Magnus
Carlsen playing this last game as white
going against your opponent playing the
petrel defense I just don't understand
why he decided to do that both sides you
could tell from the beginning they just
blitzed out of there is almost if they
were preparing for the tiebreaker they
were going so fast you know your
opponent's prepared more than anything
for this you're not gonna catch him off
guard I just don't know why he had to do
that unless he just feels very confident
that he's gonna get a draw on Monday
with the black pieces and then he can go
to the Blitz portion but thought he
might press a little bit more with the
white pieces today he did not so we do
have a day off tomorrow as we said and
then we come back for Monday for game 12
Fabiano everything rides on this with
the white pieces hopefully guys enjoyed
this game game number 11 off tomorrow
and I'll see you on Monday for game
number 12 potentially the decisive game
in the world championship 2018 see you
guys later bye